I've started on another book which I'm a
couple hundred pages in I guess and then
was there a break between these two
books at all no I was put down the pen I
I tend to fall into a foul mood when I'm
not doing something I'm not writing a
book and so I don't like to stop and
also I'm sort of you know putting
putting the long now hat on for a second
you know I am aware that I will not live
forever and so you know hopefully I'll
live for a while but I wanted to break
this habit of just stopping for a whole
year you know between between had you've
done that before yeah pretty much
so so I just decided to keep going I'm
also working part-time for a company
called magic leap which is making
augmented reality hardware of a novel
type and so that's also taking up a
bunch of my my time as well
framing yourself into a novel which is
sort of the original question the idea
for this one sort of percolated for a
couple of decades prior decade and a
half is that usually the case that you
you're you've got a number of things out
there percolating and yeah one sort of
comes to life or pretty much yeah like
the the origin of anathan was when Danny
asked me to and me and several other
people to make just back of napkin
sketches of what the clock might look
like and that was that I would have been
1999 because he wanted it for a
millennial webpage but I didn't start
writing and at them until 2005 maybe and
then reamed eaves based on the story of
the Philippine Filipino hacker who made
a virus in the early
2000's that went viral very very rapidly
over the whole the whole world and so
that was probably another five to eight
year gestation period so yeah these
things tend to kind of sit there and
ferment in the background for quite a
long time before you know kind of like
insects that you know spend a long time
in the larval state and they come out
and fly around for you know a little
while there's a one story the artists
tell each other that may or may not
relate here I'm reading a wonderful
memoir by Sally Mann the photographer
called pull the steel and in it she
mentions that photographer she knows and
I guess other artists who sort of have a
big ambitious thing they're working on
and they're grinding away on they're
grinding away on it and it's very
exciting at the beginning cuz it's all
possibility and some of them are
starting to play out and you realize
you've got something that's live and
it's taking you somewhere and you're
completely excited but by the time you
get to the end of the project it's all
punctuation yeah grinding away and
getting the laughs misspelling out of it
or the print that's actually half a
decent compared to what's in the
negative or all that kind of thing
she said what she'd run from some other
artists like I guess in Taiwan with you
what's the name that it's the healthy
thing for an artist to do is as you get
to that tiresome end game have something
else starting to crank up that is
already getting you excited again yeah
so you don't have to spend a whole lot
of time and I can't believe this is
dragging on so long can I just stop it I
hate myself all that but you can go on
to a new mode of excitement and then in
your spare time finish the punctuation
on the previous work is that what you're
finding this time around well it's
always been the case and it used to be I
would just get so distracted by the
punctuation literally that I wouldn't
even try to start something but you know
the more I do this the more I realize
that I can get bits of productive time
if I kind of budget my time well and so
yeah I'm just trying to waste as little
time as possible you're here
[Music]
you